the first caucus on Kampala 30 seconds
to make sure my MATLAB is starting
believe it or not this is about
randomized numerical linear algebra and
you don't have to take my word for it
but the topic is ordinary differential
equations so just to remind you if it's
been a while and I'm certainly no expert
on this topic
somebody's almost everything I know
about them but today I think okay so
here is the first order one you want to
figure out the evolution of this this
variable X it starts at some V and you
know let's say only its derivative time
derivative how its evolving in time and
in some interval so this is what you'd
like to do this function is reasonably
nice so at least it's Lipschitz and
that's it this is the problem soul food
but it's multi-dimensional Thanks
so this is a first-order OD because you
only took first derivative second order
ready OD would be your your second
derivative depends on first derivative
and the point you are at and time and
you're you know initial conditions for
for the point and the first event again
you want to solve up to some time window
and then of course there's a cat order
so great that's a family of problems no
okay sorry you can do whatever you want
yeah
many reasons most of which I don't know
but one thing I do know is it you know
pressing evidence that your brain is
doing this all the time if only to
balance neurons that are excitatory and
inhibitory and we reach this but
optimization I mean the the the very
successful interior point method is a
single ordinary differential equation
that you have to discretize to get out
of the mode of but the focus application
for this talk just to is sampling high
dimension distributions but not all
specific ones that seem to be of
particular interest such as sampling
from the logisitics loss function and if
you don't know this I'll mention it here
so it's a sum of one dimensional
function supplied to inner products here
and you'd like to sample so these are
all convex the whole thing is strong X
and you'd like to sample according to
this law concave density this might be
the probability of a model and you're
sampling according to loss in this if
you pick the Phi to be for example this
what is this called from the sigmoid
sorry
loss then then you get the KL divergence
is that is what you're something from
mention that but more generally maybe
you want a sample according to some some
function here we know how to do it
according to convex functions we now
rule according to strongly convex
functions we know how to occur in to
smooth strongly convex functions these
are implications but the point is that
hopefully things are getting faster and
faster and faster etc right and so all
of these classes are of interest not
just because you want to do in
polynomial time but maybe you want to do
really fast maybe this is what actually
shows up in practice on and so on
okay so here's one approach to doing
this let's think of sampling as the
continuous process diffusion it's high
dimensional sampling so look at the look
at some continuous process which at the
end of the day reaches the density you'd
like to see for example this is one way
you could do it if you want the sample
according to the density proportional to
e to the minus F you can make a change
at X this is the point in n-dimensional
space according to the gradient negative
of the gradient and this is just an
infinite small Gaussian but Brownian
motion there a scaling factor is
important if you want to get exactly you
could do this and then it's a sort of
simple application of a standard theorem
relating this to its limiting
distribution to distribution to reach
you know this this in fact the
convergence here for strongly low
concave functions there's no dependence
on the dimension it just depends on the
smoothness parameters of the function
but when you discretize if you want an
actual algorithm of course you aren't
you have to discretize and simplest way
to discretize might be
let's stay apply not influence of xt
let's look at xt plus a small h and then
that might mean that you do gradient at
the current point times h and then here
you pick a gaussian whose variance is h1
natural way to do it sorry every step
yes yeah it's a Brownian motion so it's
completely yeah right so then you
discretize you pick a Gaussian finite
variance but independent now
unfortunately if you discretize in time
with any sort of step size it actually
converges to a slightly different
distribution close depending on how
small your step size is quite different
there are variants to fix this or to
make it faster I won't discuss all of
them but this is
there's a number of interesting I
mentioned Summerlin here is one
particular approach to this which
doesn't suffer from this problem that
the discretization gives you a different
distribution and it's called Hamiltonian
Montecarlo and the idea is the following
Hamiltonian is a function of both
current position and its velocities
which means and these dynamics which we
shall put up they preserve this this
Hamiltonian so the change in the
position is the gradient with respect to
the velocity and the change in the
velocity is a negative specialist so you
can check that as you evolve these the H
itself will be maintained now this
suggests a process which is the
following at the current point X you're
gonna pick a random velocity according
to the local distribution in throw the
stock this will be just a just a
Gaussian standard Gaussian so we're
picking a random Gaussian direction and
then that direction defines a curve and
it defines where you go the starting
velocity defines where you will go to
follow that for some discrete time so
this Hamiltonian defines a curve that
maintains some function you haven't
defined yet we will define function
because we need to have a goal what's
the end result we want out of this
sampling from some density so we can do
this very generally the same slide but
now you pick H to be something like this
think of G is just identity for this
talk but you can actually make it more
general if G is just identity this is
just you know the square of the velocity
itself energy and that's the function
and this is a constant so this term just
drops out when G is identity so we're
saying set Hamiltonian to be the
function plus you could say to half of
we squared so in the standard way and
then look at the derivatives
X is just the velocity DX by DT is just
B this is halfway square you get me
excuse me
you mind if I take this one G in general
is so at each point you don't have to
sample from the same Gaussian you have
the flexibility of defining Gaussian
depending on the local point and in one
way to do it would be to have a local
metric for example the Hessian of some
convex function yeah but right now yes
it's pretty prefix but right for getting
it what I'm going to do and maybe I
should have done that it's just I just
think of G's identity so yeah so you can
evolve I mean you need the direction
it's it's a so the nice thing about this
is that yeah it's completely symmetric
and unlike almost any other process that
natural in Canada to be efficient
it doesn't require a rejection step to
get your right distribution even though
it's discrete-time okay so so this is
the process focus process mind here but
note of course that we have to solve and
differential equation to make a step
right so I I have a current X and a
current B and after time delta I want to
know where will this X in X be the way
I'm going to reap it so it doesn't ok so
here are some representative guarantees
for for sampling if we took to take the
completely general law concave setting
then there are discrete methods that
take roughly cubic in the dimension for
a point if you want to do uniform in a
polytope you can do that with with
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo and actually for
a polytope with M facets you get this
bound which is sub quadratic which turns
out to be impossible for these methods
there's some evidence of a win for this
method I mentioned other diffusion
methods which we have to do some
correction for but nevertheless they
work for under stronger
so strongly low concave and Sami la
concave with further assumptions you get
even better dependence on the dimensions
square root n and n to the 1/4 even and
this Kappa here is a condition number so
it measures the local smoothness roughly
speaking you take the Hessian or at
least the surfaces look at the maximum
eigen value and we don't magnate value
in the ratio of that right so the
Jovovich maximum ratio of largest to
smallest eigen value so that's the
condition number Kappa here so this was
all the authors are here
this is mangu B and Vishnu being slit
and I haven't put this up here for the
following reason the number of steps so
there's an addition the assumption from
going from here to here
is that besides being strongly low
concave it's also smooth we also have
all the derivatives not just the first
two is that the number of steps here
abstractly depends only on the condition
number as Kappa squared doesn't even
depend on dimension but unfortunately
implementing each step has a has a
penalty dimension and its various
trade-offs here son
okay so before we go back to the Eau de
odio sort of show you how the audience
are connected to even the analysis of
these these methods because they're to
the main part of the talk and and and
and how the condition numbers come into
the picture so let's say we start with a
function f convex and moreover it's it's
strongly convex in this sense lower
bound and upper bound sonnets haitian
eigenvalues then what we can show is
that for time up to this is a number
that depends on this condition numbers
right so if they are constant this is up
to some constant time if you start out
at points x and y and just run this
process using the same directions at
each time so you take two copies of the
process x and y but you're starting at
two different locations that's all it
means right every time when they when
you pick the same Gaussian vector for
both of them
can you guess what will eventually
happen
they added meat because of the strong
law of concavity they will actually meet
and the question is how fast and now
this already allows you to prove that
things must mix fast because pretend one
of them is already random and the other
one is arbitrary and over time they are
getting together and actually coupling
to become the same so the further the
pointer was arbitrary became random no
question is how fast did this happen so
the the trivial coupling of just
identity use the same direction works
because the gradient of the function is
helping you go to the same place and
it's strongly low concave so the
gradients are kind of pointing you in
the same global to the same global point
no matter where you start and that's
enough to so so the contraction bound
here is 1 minus this this lower bound on
the eigenvalues times the x squared and
so if you set this time to the largest
possible which would be the biggest step
you can take so you get the most
contraction is by solving a single OD e
for that setting even check it's M over
m to the three-halves which means that
the mixing rate is a part of the
three-halves which grows a little bit on
the previous list Kappa squared Kappa is
the best possible and not entirely clear
whether we can do better than three
halves or not so here is one sort of
straightforward open problem this
process or any process can you get it to
do mix in just copper
yes yeah exactly yeah so this lower
condition is the one that is the factory
of marry criteria the the lower bound on
the yes is a battery every criterion for
the watt concave doesn't seem to satisfy
lakhs Opel an equality but this is
connected to the contraction rates for
the lack of infinitesimally group
generated by something else is there a
relationship between this and
Hamiltonian dynamics so
what is what I do know that's related
what you're asking is that for the
Langevin dynamics it's sufficient to
have a long so blob inequality to prove
convergence at least for the continuous
one here yeah we're doing a direct
coupling justifying the contraction here
yeah certainly this satisfies along
sovereign quality or not using it
directly yeah right as far as I know
that process is still at Kappa square
okay so why does this contraction happen
right so this is one step so this just
solving this these paths and I guess I
should draw something these paths are
you're starting somewhere and there's a
gradient
pointing in some sense towards global
optimum and so these paths are somehow
bringing you closer to each other that's
the proof has to analyze this this
differential equation right this is just
the same thing that for the further for
the Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
remember the Hamilton Monte Carlo just
said that the derivative of the current
point is the velocity and the derivative
of the velocity is the minus the
gradient
maybe I should write that here since
this is how you're starting and then
velocity itself which will keep changing
so it's the second derivative of the
position
but the negative gradient of the
function
that's that that's that's dynamic yes
the fact that you have you're going to
as a baby can only give you sampling or
mixing if it strongly convex so for
example if you were trying to uniform
and a polytope or or any function that's
not strongly convex this this proof
method yeah yeah so the one of the
results I put up there was uniform in a
polytope right that has to use a variant
it doesn't use coupling it uses a
conductance proof shows that the
expansion is large and so on okay so we
already discussed this you're planning
to couple and together so let's look at
this quantity between the two processes
Y and X so there's two copies I mean two
different points at which you're
starting and the idea of the coupling is
you pick the same velocity fine look at
this difference and we want to see how
this evolves over time so it starts at
something at T equal to zero we want to
see where this goes okay so by the
definition of the process the second
derivative of this is you know the
difference of these derivatives that's
just the difference in the gradients
right at every time T that's so we want
to know how this differential equation
really evolves to show that it it it's
solution over time decreases in norm so
just rewriting this in terms of the
hessian and now parama tries to make the
zero one that's why I have this let me
call this quantity here which is like an
average of the hessian on the line from
xt to whitey
that's all it is on the line from exceed
yd they're averaging the hessian in this
direction so that's that's that's what
we have now
and yeah the solution to this should be
this integral I just I've just
integrated twice on both sides for this
term and if you have not done it before
after you integrate twice you have to
switch the the integrals to to get the t
minus s out and then okay so far so good
and so then just take norms and you see
that the bound on the normalization will
be useful that's all I've done here now
this here is a one-dimensional
inequality right interviewing inequality
but it's one dimensional so you can say
very generally that if you have any such
one-dimensional inequality V of T at
most beta plus gamma times similar
expression right t minus s times V of s
where beta and gamma are are
non-negative then in fact the general
solution for this is that it's at most
beta times the hyperbolic cosine of
square root gamma T it's like a I guess
an exercise in differential equations of
course sequence
substituting check okay so so using this
it tells you that this quantity here
just applying the lemma beta is the
initial norm gamma is the patient's
largest eigenvalue you get some and for
T not too large you get a bound on the
length so the vs. is saying is that this
this this distance cannot become too big
it could grow but it cannot become much
bigger than what it sucks it up to this
time though and in fact once you have
this bound on this distance upper bound
it also gives you a lower bound right
because I can put it back here and say
that I can't be subtract for every step
of the way and therefore I can't be
subtracting it too much either so you
get the bound on both sides it stays up
to this time between one point two and
point eight it doesn't change much now
this sounds a little contrary to what we
want to show we already saw it shrinks
right we're saying it doesn't go crazy
but that's the problem with these proofs
if it goes crazy then you're you know
you can't prove anything here it's
staying control so in this region we
hope to make progress we should be
making progress because everything
is pointing in the right direction it's
a negative sign it's the Hessian
positive definite and so on so so using
this bound we can actually argue that
the squared length of the distance
compared to the initial contracts and
this rate and then just use the now the
point is that because you know it's
strongly not concave this quadratic form
here has a lower bound and that gives
you minimum contract I haven't shown you
how this inequality is derived but the
basic idea is to split this vector DT
into the coordinate along the line
joining the two points and the
orthogonal part and you make progress in
the line joining the two so that was
motivation for why we want to do this
kind of or really both in a balanced and
an algorithm now there are many this is
a huge literature I think it's about
comparable to randomized numerical
linear algebra for matrices and solving
linear systems and and so on there are
many books rich field like new
algorithms closely related also you'll
see discovering and the classical
results you know about uniqueness about
convergence you know no matter where you
start and for how long very general and
lots of really clean clean things our
goal here is you know we wanna take
algorithmic guarantees so I want fast
and non asymptotic guarantees right so
this will by that I mean I want a
solution of error epsilon in time no
more than some function and regardless
of where you start you can't tell me if
you start close enough it'll work no no
give me a starting point as part of the
other okay so back to first order OD so
here not a completely general problem
you can forget it if you don't like
sampling can't imagine why but forget
about it here
right it's multi-dimensional now okay so
you just integrate both sides right so
so integrate both sides okay so you know
what X 0 is and I just wrote an integral
there so what you do next so it's very
much like solving linear systems right
it's an iteration where you you you just
start with some trivial solution like
the right hand side and then you keep
operating on the residue that's the plan
weird figure out what the right operator
is it's not my plan this is the plan of
the field and and it works really well
so let's think of this operator tau
which is basically mapping these you
think of X itself as a function for at
every time X as a function it's telling
you what the values are so functions
function it's modifying this function
the next step the next x is a function
of the previous X now that means that
what we're really solving at the end of
the day if you solve it is x equals tau
effects so now modifying it doesn't
change anything
it's a fixed point of this well by very
general considerations no fixed point
theorem it's enough if this operator tau
is T is tau is a contraction it will
exist and will be unique and everything
will be nice so we need the Lipschitz
constant to be less than 1 and here
Lipschitz constant is just it's just
comes in the best because that's
constant and this is a 0 1 so if the
response is less than 1 it constant but
you know you have some OD
why should this Lipschitz constant be
less than 1 maybe it's Lipschitz but not
as of course this is dealt with in in
the literature what if it's a listen to
some hell and this type of it just says
imagine operating this operator not just
once but J times okay in one step you
couldn't get a contraction perhaps but
let's look at J pans and now basically
I'm defining this norm as the maximum
over this time interval that you're
looking at and if the Lipschitz constant
for one step right for the function
itself was L
I should have l Samaria ellipse its then
for this operator applied J times its LT
to the J / J factorial where T is the
time interval you're going for so now by
making J high enough you can make this
less than 1 which literally means but
just by composing eventually your
contract there is a fixed point so all
you need is the function Lipchitz you
haven't seen a course in the film
division before there's a proof of
uniqueness in existence right okay I was
gonna prove it but I think I would have
time but here's the next question okay
so this is the general theorem that
there exists this but how do you turn
this into an hour yes so the natural
iteration would be to do exactly what we
did write the most general fixed point
algorithm is just apply that operator
the trouble is X is a function here how
are you going to represent it this
entire interval right how do we
represent it we can do separately for
each coordinate that's not a problem so
the idea is you know functions also have
basis okay of course they could have
could be infinite but let's hope that
the solution to the so de is close to
some finite dimensional basis so you
could pick a polynomial basis for
Fourier basis or some nice basis but in
that basis of functions that your
solution to your OD is close to that
okay so for example if you had this
basis and you pick some evaluation
points so now the idea is instead of
maintaining the entire function you're
just going to maintain its values at
certain it's a small set of points so if
you had if you picked up on 100 basis
for example we just need to evaluate it
as as many points with the degree and
keep those around for all the basis
functions so that's the plan you can
always pick an orthogonal basis and then
this is just saying that every function
this is the basis every function can be
written like this because I think there
are thousand abysus I know this leads us
to the method that's the natural
iteration so
however we implement implementing it
taking our terminal basis taking nice
points for the polynomial basis we can
use this lagrange basis you can check
that this places satisfies this at this
point CI it's it's 1 and otherwise it's
J and in fact it has sort of bounded
norm it's not something that has very
huge coefficients great now if indeed
the solution to your OD e is
approximable by a low degree polynomial
or degree of some degree d degree k then
you can write it again in terms of this
basis and then the derivative by
definition of e is this function and now
you're computing only at the points the
test points there's your iteration
that's the algorithm so we're going to
keep computing the function at these
test points that's this is the
collocation method it's one of just want
to point out that it's a it's a super
fast method because you're just doing
basically a matrix matrix product but
this is a pre-computer matrix
so using this I won't have time to
mention later but I was going to tell
you it this is highly parallel also
complex is just a number of iterations
paralyzed about okay so this is the
guide until you get if you had started
with that first order OD e and you
assumed that there was a good polynomial
approximation using a basis of size D
then if you start with any Lipschitz
function the collocation algorithm finds
you a solution obviously a polynomial
because that's what it's finding whose
error is as small Absalon as you want
and the running time the number of
iterations is only log 1 over epsilon
log 1 over epsilon each iteration has d
function evaluations where d was the
degree of the polynomial
- HM see this was the algorithm for
Hamilton in Monte Carlo and now we need
to show why should these Odie's have
low-degree solutions otherwise the whole
thing or Fourier basis why should they
have only a few Fourier coefficients we
need to prove that otherwise it's all up
in the air game so to do this now it
depends on the properties of F if you
develop an approach which generalizes
this notion of Ecology estimates for one
variable functions i should stop in a
minute we can estimate K its derivatives
if you know that the function has its
complex differentiable in a neighborhood
and gives you a bound on all its
derivatives in a small in a small
neighborhood now why are there a video
is useful because then you can look at
the Taylor series and if your
derivatives are decreasing fast enough
then you truncate that's the plan so but
how do you do it for high dimensional
functions we can develop a calculus to
do these inequalities basically if you
define the norm of KH directional
derivatives then you get these calculus
rules let's say for example if set of
inequalities are true for functions
capital F and small F then is true for
the sound it's true for product and so
on
using these if you wanted to bound this
general OD here I put second-order
because that's what happens in H and C
you can bound the Lipschitz Ness in
terms of one-dimensional functions which
satisfy one-dimensional Odie's problem
of bounding the Lipschitz constants of
this general high dimension functions
becomes one of problem burning it for
one-dimensional functions and indeed in
our application we just at the end of
the day have to bound the values for
this function a over 1 minus C T and
that's enough to get there all the
bounds for logistic loss let me just put
up the result here's what you get this
is for general functions Phi but for the
log one you get linear in end and copper
to the 1.5 that's the total time plus o
tilde one function evaluations that's a
listen a lot so it's actually truly
linear times the condition number two
the one pointless collocation I
mentioned it's parable and can extend it
in other ways lots of open problems here
complexity of OD e is for example order
L possible I meant little o is all well
possible yeah we have three hubs is
better than L possible now that might be
difficult because that would actually
improve the interior point complexity
from Luton to the world I can't see
good question when the next
[Applause]
you know in this what we've done so far
explicitly use the explicit knowledge of
the of the polynomial basis you know the
functions in the basis to pre compute
their coefficients you are asking if it
happens to be sparse can you solve it
yeah I don't know that would be very
nice
[Applause]